ALLON COHEN: Thank
you for joining.
And welcome to our
session on "File
Storage for
High-Performance Workloads."
I'm Allon.
And I'm joined today by Gilles
from our Google Silicon Team.
And we'll be presenting
to you "File Usage
for High-Performance Workloads."
Before I begin, a
little bit about myself,
my name is Dr. Allon Cohen.
I'm a 15-year veteran of the
enterprise storage industry.
And I recently joined Google
through the acquisition
of the Elastifile.
Elastifile developed
the technology
that is at the base of many
of the new capabilities
that we'll be
presenting to you today.
So let's dive right in.
File storage essentially powers
many high-performance workloads
in Google Cloud and
throughout the industries,
whether it's rendering
of the latest blockbuster
movies, discovery
in life sciences,
including drug
discovery for dealing
with the latest pandemics,
or any such industry,
such as silicon and EDA.
But the truth of the matter is
that file architectures are not
a one-size-fit-all technology.
Essentially, if you
have a small workload,
you can use a local file
system that provides you access
to one VM accessing that data.
But as you grow your systems
and want to share more data,
shared file systems allow
you to essentially connect
multiple VMs or containers
to a single file system
through simplified interfaces
and protocols such as NFS.
But as your needs grow and
as you need more and more
compute power, it is not
just enough to scale compute.
You also need to scale the
back-end file system to support
those demanding workloads.
And that's where you need
scalable file systems, which
also come in two flavors.
Parallel of file
systems allow you
to connect using plugins
on the client side
to multiple back-end
storage nodes,
while scale out file
system essentially retains
the simplicity of
shared file systems,
allowing you to connect
through protocols such as NFS,
while at the same time
assuring that the storage
at the back end can
also scale and match
the performance requirements
of your front-end systems.
But moving HPC
workloads to cloud
is not just about
performance there
is a collection of features that
you require to easily migrate
your workloads into the cloud.
Beyond the high capacity
and high performance,
you want the elasticity
to grow and shrink
on demand to really benefit
from what the cloud provides.
You want to retain the
simplicity of your local file
system and the way
you use your scale
out file systems within
your environments.
You want to be able to
provision on demand.
integrate with cloud schedulers
so that you do not
need to manually manage
the environment.
And you want that file
system to maintain natively
all of the attributes of the
file systems, such as locking,
that you used within
your on-prem environment.
That is the reason that we
are excited to introduce
to you Filestore High Scale.
Filestore High Scale is a new
tier of Google's Filestore
product that is essentially a
managed elastic scale out file
service that is designed to
match the requirements of HPC
and HTC workloads.
With Filestore High Scale, we
are extending the capacities
of the Filestore you're
used to to capacities
of up to 320 terabytes.
We are supporting a background
scale out architecture.
We are allowing you
now to both grow
and shrink your environments
for high-scale instances.
And we expand the
performance of Filestore
to over 16 gigabytes per
second, or more than tenfold
of our previous capabilities.
In terms of IOPS, you can now
reach hundreds of thousands
of IOPS.
And even more so,
and more importantly,
for HPC environments,
you can now
connect thousands of
front-end machines
to the back-end storage.
With these new capabilities,
essentially, Filestore
enables you to migrate your
workloads into the cloud.
You can now run all
types of HPC workload
with a native NFS file
system inside the cloud,
connect to it using either
the VMs or containers.
And we'll even
demonstrate to you
shortly that you can
use preemptible VMs
and save considerable costs
on your compute-side storage.
You can now support
life sciences workloads,
manufacturing,
finance, and more.
To demonstrate to
you how such a file
system is used in
production, I'm
going to turn it over
to Gilles to present
to us how they use this
technology for their EDA
workload.
GILLES-ERIC DESCAMPS:
Thank you, Allon.
Hi, everybody.
I'm Gilles.
I've been lucky to have
been able to implement
world-class networking,
CPU, GPUs, and mobile SOCs
at different companies.
I've also been into the software
industry, supporting enterprise
and personal batch
queuing software.
And now, for two
and a half years,
I've been at
Google, implementing
world-class silicon.
Our needs are those of a
typical HPC/EDA customer.
We rely on a lot of
third-party commercial software
that we assembled
into flows, each one
with hundreds of steps.
Our users use mix of interactive
tool sessions and also batch
workloads across
thousands of machines.
They share their data by using
large data files that they want
to share with their colleagues.
And our application is
not a web application.
We cannot afford to
lose a single job.
Otherwise, it may hit the scale
up to two weeks, for example.
Finally, we operate worldwide
in multiple continents.
Our initial assessment
of Filestore in 2018
before we took that
journey was, it
look good that it was
simple to instantiate.
It was compatible
with Terraform,
so we could use
infrastructure as code.
It was managed, so
we didn't not have
to spend time watching how
is the machine performing.
Somebody else was
guaranteeing us that.
We were using
20-terabyte machines.
And Filestore offered
up to 64 terabytes.
So that was great.
And it also grows online.
So we could start
with small machine
and add more capacity as needed.
The problems we identified
were, was the file system
a server file system,
or just a file system?
And in the end, it's managed.
So we didn't care about
those implementation details.
The big one which was initially
throttling us was there
were no user or
[INAUDIBLE] quotas.
So how do we make this work?
We decided to
allocate one per user.
And finally, we identified
that it was just
nice to have to have the
feature of reducing online.
Our cloud architecture
is based on using
one cloud project per chip.
Each user gets a virtual
Desktop into the cloud,
which is basically a RHEL
7 machine inside your web
browser.
Those can be quite large, with
96 CPUs and 2 terabyte of RAM.
All the design files are stored
on the NFS Filestore server.
We allocate at
least one per user.
And we rely on that amount
to enable collaborations,
so that each person can
see other users' file.
And finally, we deployed
the batch-queuing system
so that we can
maximize license usage.
And the machines in the farm
auto-amount the needed data
from Filestore.
So how did it go?
We started back in 2017
with 50-gig machine.
And Filestore turned out to
be easy, reliable, and scaled.
We went in production
with a beta service.
We started with a
dozen Filestores.
And we ended up growing way
past our plans and expectation.
So we have to say,
thanks to the cloud
for delivering to us unlimited
and instant capacity.
We ended up reaching close
to 500 Filestore servers,
totaling 4.2-petabyte
capacity, worldwide.
And so despite having 500 file
servers, it was easy to manage.
Between Terraform and the
management of Filestore,
it was great.
It was also very reliable.
We never lost a single byte,
despite having 4.2 petabytes.
We had a couple of incidents.
And they were mostly
related to performance
of temporarily unavailable
data for a few hours.
The great thing that we
discovered with Filestore
is, you all know what is
the typical sysadmin duty.
A system administrator has to
ensure that one user cannot
bring down other users
by abusing the systems.
And so at other companies,
with a traditional file server
appliance, I have personally
experienced the overload
of a file server when an
HPC application deploys
across thousands of cores.
So it's very
difficult to identify
where the load is coming from.
The NFS protocol has no
quality of service built in.
So Filestore gave us the
I/O quality of service
we did not know we needed.
It solved by
construction [INAUDIBLE]..
There was no way a
single user could
impact the work of other users.
And finally, performance--
Filestore was able to provide
enough IOPS and capacity
for most of our application.
Only the static
timing signoff, which
runs across hundreds of corners,
was too much for one Filestore.
So we mitigated this
performance bottleneck
by manually sharding the runs
across multiple Filestore
per user.
Now we are currently exploring
Filestore High Scale.
And our users are
reporting that they
are liking shared
write, the fact
that you can size
higher than 64 terabyte,
and that some workloads
are running way faster than
on a single Filestore.
Now back to you, Allon.
ALLON COHEN: Thank you, Gilles.
So with that, we would like to
actually demo the system to you
and its new capabilities.
We are going to simulate an HPC
workload using a Filestore High
Scale instance.
We are going to automate
that using Slurm.
And then we are going to spin
up thousands of preemptible VMs,
connect them to the
back-and Filestore system,
and demonstrate to you some of
these supported performance.
The first step is, of course,
launching a Filestore instance.
That is very simple, done
through the cloud console.
And essentially, it runs in
a very similar way to the way
you're used to launching
Filestore instances so far.
But we add that capability of
launching high scale instances,
allowing you to launch them with
up to 320 terabytes of storage
in a single file system.
You can select the
region and the zone
where you want to launch.
You can select the
network that you
want to use and even control
access using certain IPs.
You name your Filestore.
Let's do next2020.
And just press Create.
This is a fully managed system,
so the scale out file system
is being launched for
us at the back end.
And once it's ready,
we simply have
an IP that we can start
mounting clients to.
We'll do that now with
Slurm for orchestration,
launching thousands
of preemptible VMs.
Back in Cloud
Console, we can see
that those VMs are launching.
And at the same time, Slurm
is now initiating jobs
within each of those clients.
And those jobs connect to
the Filestore High Scale
instance at the back end.
These are all preemptible VMs.
So Slurm can launch
them while saving over
80% of the cost in terms of
the compute for the systems
that you are using.
At the top portion
of this screen,
you see the number of
connections and the throughput
that is being generated
by these workloads
as they run these jobs.
You can see that
we are now already
at about 2,000 connections to
our back-end Filestore High
Scale instance.
And you can also see that
our throughput is reaching
25 gigabytes per second,
allowing all of these clients
to run in parallel.
Now, because these clients are
running on preemptible VMs,
it may occur--
and at this number, it
definitely does occur--
that some of these VMs
will actually be preempted.
But that is not an issue
for this architecture,
because our orchestration
system will essentially just
spin up these VMs again to
complete the jobs that they
were running.
All of the data is
persisted in Filestore High
Scale at the back end.
So the data is not
lost, even though our VM
has been preempted.
So as you can see now, Slurm is
relaunching VMs and making sure
that our whole job
process has completed.
And that is the
tale of completion
that you see at the
back of this run.
So what we demonstrate
here, essentially we
launched a 320-terabyte
scale out file system
at the back end with a series
of clicks from Cloud console.
We made sure that we
can run preemptible VMs,
and launched, in this
case, 2,000 preemptible VMs
against this single
scale out file system.
There is no overhead, because
with this orchestration,
you can essentially launch
the VMs when you need them.
And when they are
no longer needed,
you simply spin them down.
Everything is persistent
on the file system.
And even the file
system itself, you
can scale up and scale down
on demand for your needs.
We connected thousands
of VMs in parallel.
We showed over-- well over,
actually, 16 gigabytes
per second of throughput.
And we completed 100%
of our processing.
And all of the data was
persisted in our back-end file
system.
If you would like to
learn more about Filestore
and its new capabilities,
you can check them out
in the links provided
in this slide.
But the proof of the
pudding is in the eating.
So we welcome you to
go to Cloud Console,
launch a Filestore
High Scale instance,
and test your own workloads to
see the performance that you
achieve.
With that, I'd like to thank
Gilles again for joining me.
Thank you all for being here.
And we look forward to
receiving your questions
and getting your feedback
on usage of the system.
Thank you.